SVEN MAWSON: All right,
thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm going to get started now
as a couple more people
straggle in.
I appreciate everyone
coming to this.
My name is Sven Mawson.
I'm going to be talking to you
about optimizing your code,
and in particular about
optimizing API access to
Google's APIs.
So we're not going to cover
all of optimization.
That's a pretty wide topic.
There's a lot of interesting
talks at Google I/O to go
learn about such things, but I'm
going to be focused really
on what you can do with the
features that we provide as
part of the APIs to make your
life much easier and make your
code run a lot faster.
And again you can use
the hashtag #io12 to
discuss this talk.
All right.
So why would you be interested
in optimizing your API access?
Well, why are you interested
in optimizing
your code in general?
If you're a web developer or
a mobile developer, you're
probably well aware of the
limitations of those platforms
in terms of some of the CPU
constraints and some of the
bandwidth constraints.
So you really want to make your
code as fast as possible
to make your user experience
better.
So speed really is one of the
features of your applications.
It's not an afterthought.
It's actually one of the prime,
most important features.
And we at Google especially
know this.
You're all familiar with how
fast Google searches.
We put a lot of effort into
that, and it really shows and
it makes the user experience
so, so much better.
And in fact, it actually can
lead directly to more users
coming in because if your
application is faster than
your competitors, it's a huge
competitive advantage and
you'll win every time.
So it's really important.
Not only that, but also
bandwidth is very important
because it's expensive.
It's hard to read that.
Bandwidth costs money, not only
to you if you're, for
example, using App
Engine, you're
paying for the bandwidth.
But to users as well, if they're
on mobile plans that
are not unlimited, which almost
none of them are these
days, your users are actually
paying for the bandwidth.
So if you're writing a mobile
application, you really want
to be careful to use as little
bandwidth as possible.
And along with saving your users
money, you also actually
make your app faster in the
process, because it uses less
memory, it uses less CPU.
Things are really,
really nice.
All right.
To sort of frame this discussion
of how to make your
API access faster, I'm going
to show you an example
application I built just really
to show what you can do
with Google APIs and how
to make them faster.
So this application is
built on App Engine.
Hopefully you all are familiar
with App Engine.
And it's a task management
application.
So it's very similar to the
TaskList that Google provides.
It lets you create lists
of items and add them.
And it's integrated with a
couple different Google APIs.
So the first one it's integrated
with is Google
Drive, and this lets you
actually store the Tasks
inside Google Drive as
little documents.
So each TaskList is a document
in Google Drive.
You can actually share
them with people.
You can edit them.
There's no collaborative editing
yet because I built
this on Drive SDK 1.
SDK 2 actually has collaborative
editing.
So if I'm feeling ambitious,
I might extend my
application with that.
It integrates with Tasks, so it
actually can sync back to
the Google Tasks API, and it's
also integrated with Calendar,
so you can set due dates on your
Tasks and have them show
up in Calendar.
So I'm going to give you
a little demo of
how that all works.
So I actually have, already in
My Drive, some TaskLists.
Actually I call them
super lists.
So we can click on
one, for example.
This will load up my application
on App Spot, as
you can see.
It's an App Engine
application.
It's quite an ugly UI.
I apologize.
I'm a back-end engineer, not
a front-end engineer.
So things are a little ugly.
And in fact, you can
open a new one.
If I go look at My Tasks, for
example, you can see this.
I think that's the
same one, yeah.
So, related sessions.
Let's say I decide that I want
another one in here.
Actually, let's not
do it in this one.
Let's do it over here.
So let's add a new session
to go see.
Anyone have an example, a good
session they're interested in
seeing that I should
add to this list?
Anyone, anyone?
No?
Endpoints?
Yeah.
You should definitely learn
about endpoints.
So Google Cloud Endpoints,
which is awesome.
All right.
So if I save that, I can save
it, then in theory it will
show up, when it finishes
saving, back in here.
I might have to refresh it.
There it is.
OK.
So the sync, very exciting.
I can add a due date to that.
Let's see, I should
see that today.
Save that.
And in theory, this will of
course save into calendar.
Things sync.
Things take time.
There it is.
Voila.
OK.
So you've seen the
application.
Very exciting.
It's integrated with those
various systems, but
it's not that fast.
So we're going to
make it faster.
First of all, I'm just going
to go through some of the
code, so you see the
starting place.
And then from there, we'll work
towards actually making
it move along quickly.
So the first thing I'm going
to talk about is really,
really briefly, authentication.
There are many talks about
authentication.
You all know it's a pretty
painful subject.
I cheat by just using the code
that the Drive team already
wrote for me.
So on the Drive documentation
site, there's an example in
Java, called Doctor Edit, that
does the Drive authentication
basically for you.
I just pulled that code in.
You create it, you
call, get active
credential, and you're done.
You don't worry about
anything.
So it's very simple.
I recommend checking that out
if you're doing a Drive app.
Make your life much easier.
OK.
So let's say we have that.
How do I actually call
the Drive API?
So it's actually very easy.
I should preface this by
saying that all of the
examples are going to be using
the Java client library for
Google APIs.
Most of this is applicable
to other client
libraries as well.
The Java client is the farthest
along with the
performance features, so I'm
going to focus on that.
But if you're using a different
library, different
language, don't worry.
We have you covered.
OK.
So in Java, we create a
Drive service here.
And then if I want to get a
particular file, I just call
service.files.get.
That creates a request object.
If anyone was here in the
previous session about the
JavaScript API, it's
very similar.
You execute methods that create
request objects, and
then you call execute on them.
And you'll see the reason
for that later.
But in this case, then we just
call execute, and we get back
a file object which has all
of the file metadata.
Now in Drive, files are
split into two parts.
There's the metadata part,
which has things like the
title, the last modified time,
the text search metadata.
You can add things like that.
There's actually a fair
amount in there.
But the actual content of the
file is stored as a binary
blob, and it's not stored
in that file.
After you get back, you have
to make another call.
So that's what this
second section is.
So this is the important
part right here.
That request object we've
created earlier actually has
this cool Get Media HTTP
Downloader method on it that
gives you this downloader
object.
You call download
with the URL.
In this case, the URL that
we're using is from that
initial request.
So the way Drive works is to
get the content, you first
have to get the metadata,
which includes
a link to the content.
And that's a secure link.
So you have to do it that way.
You have to do two requests
to get it.
And then in my application,
I'm storing this as a JSON
blob, so it's just text data.
So I create a string
from the bytes.
Because the Drive API doesn't
know what you're
going to do with it.
It could be an image,
for all it knows.
OK, so that's Drive.
What about the other APIs.
So the next one I integrated
with was TaskList.
One of the things they didn't
show you in the very quick
demo there is that you can
actually take one of my super
lists and just create
a TaskList from it.
So here's how you
would do that.
You just create the object.
Well, first you do the
same kind of thing.
You create the Task service.
It's identical to Drive,
just a different name.
Then you create a TaskList,
set the title, call
Tasklists.Insert right here.
You get that TaskList,
and again it
creates a request object.
You call execute on that, and it
gives you back your result.
And we actually need the result,
because we're going to
insert a bunch of
items into it.
And to insert the items,
you need the ID.
And the ID you got back from
that first request.
So pretty standard.
You create Tasks, call insert,
give it the ID and object.
It gives you back the
inserted one.
Actually, it gives you back
the request insert.
You execute that, and it gives
you back the inserted one.
All I care about is the
ID, because I'm
actually going to do sync.
So I need the IDs to do
the synchronization.
So I keep track of that
in item.taskid.
Very simple.
Not too exciting.
Similar idea with Calendar.
You just create a calendar
service.
You call events.get.
In this case, I'm going to use
the user's primary calendar.
I don't feel like putting up
a picker to let them choose
which calendar to use.
I just always use
the primary one.
Save myself some effort.
And in this case, we're
actually doing a sync.
So I want to get the existing
calendar event to figure out
its due date and title to see
if I need to update them.
So first I get them all, and
then in a loop I go over them
and update them all.
All right.
So that's the code of how the
application works, but again,
what we really care about is
making this fast, right?
So the first thing, if you're
ever trying to make an
application fast, is understand
where it's slow.
So we've all heard early
optimization is
the root of all evil.
I think a more appropriate term
would be optimization
without profiling is the
root of all evil.
If you're spending all of your
time on optimizing 10% of the
actual time spent by your
application, you're not going
to make any big gain.
So we really need to know, where
is our time being spent,
so we can actually
upgrade things.
So in this case, I'm going to
look at four different actions
that the user initiates.
The first is just load.
So if I ever go to one of my
lists and just hit refresh,
that's a load action.
You can see, I'll actually
show you on this.
If I just hit refresh,
that's a load.
And the metrics on the
right-hand side there are all
my information about
what took time.
So I'll talk about that now.
The other actions are saving,
and then syncing to Tasks and
syncing to Calendar.
So we have our actions, and then
we also have the things
that we're actually measuring.
So for this talk, we're going
to be focused on both speed
and bandwidth.
So latency, how long the
actions took, and then
bandwidth, how much of the wire
did it actually use up?
And for the bandwidth, we're
actually only going to look at
response size.
There's a lot more things you
could look at, but just to
keep things simple for the sake
of this demo and talk.
So how do we actually do this?
Who here is familiar with
Guava for Java?
Anyone?
You all should go get familiar,
if you're Java
engineers, get familiar
with Guava.
It's awesome.
Guava is a set of libraries
that Google provides.
It's sort of the best of.
You could think of it as the
greatest hits of internal Java
development at Google.
I don't just say that because
my name is on some of the
code, because it's actually
really cool.
My name is not on Stopwatch,
which I'm using here.
But Stopwatch is awesome.
It's really just a very
easy way to do timing.
So you create a stopwatch, you
call start, you call stop.
And it has this really nice
two-string method that you
just give it.
There is actually a default of
four, but you can give it the
number of significant digits.
And it'll print it in an
appropriate unit based on how
long it took.
So if it was in millisecond
range, it'll say 10.56
milliseconds or whatever.
If it was in seconds,
it'll print in that.
If it's in minutes, it'll
print in that.
You don't have to write that
code that I'm sure all of you
have written, where you take a
timer and you're like, OK, is
it less than 1,000?
And you try and figure out
what it fits into.
That's all taken care
of for you.
And I put it into this metrics
map that you saw on the
right-hand side.
It had all those metrics.
And I'm just printing that out
through the side channel
there, just to make my life
a little bit easier.
If you were doing this in more
of a real application, you'd
probably log this somewhere that
you can then analyze it
in more detail later, or use
something like analytics.
OK.
So that's latency.
Bandwidth, as I mentioned,
I'm only looking at
the response sizes.
And in fact, I'm only looking at
the response bodies just to
make things much simpler.
And part of the reason for this
is, the application is a
App Engine app that's talking
to Google APIs.
So there's nowhere in
that interaction for
me to insert myself.
You could run it locally and use
something like Wireshark
in the dev server mode and try
and get it, but I wanted the
what's going on in the real
world when it's actually
deployed situation.
So I'm just using the
content length from
the response headers.
So really I'm trusting
Google to give me the
right content length.
And since I was the one that set
that content length, I'm
trusting myself.
So you do what you've
got to do.
But really it's just we're
tracking response length.
Not too exciting.
So let's look at some
numbers from the
first draft of my code.
So we have a load that is a
read from Drive and a read
from Tasks.
You saw on the demo, on the
left-hand side it shows all
the TaskLists.
That's that read.
We also have the read of
the current content.
And again, that's both
phases of that.
That's reading the metadata
and reading the content.
Save is similar.
It's a read from Drive, in this
case only the metadata,
so it's shorter.
And a write to Drive of both
metadata and the content.
And then Tasks and Events are
similarly again read, write.
So we read all the current
Tasks, we write them all to
the server, we read all the
current Events, we write them
all to the server.
It takes a lot of time.
And I should mention that in
all of these cases, I'm
looking at a list of 20 items.
So it's important when
you do profiling to
compare apples to apples.
You actually want to make sure
you control for things.
So you don't want different
sized lists each time.
You want to actually make sure
you're doing the same thing,
and in fact the same actions.
So in this case, I do five
inserts, five updates, and
five deletes, in both cases, of
the Tasks and Events, just
to make sure things
are consistent.
All right.
So that was latency.
What about bandwidth?
This is, again, response
bandwidth.
And they're basically the exact
same actions, or service
calls, you saw.
So there's reads from the
different services and writes.
Again, not very interesting.
But you see that events,
for example,
take up a lot of space.
Maybe we should focus on that.
You can take this information
and try and figure out what to
do with it.
All right.
So that's all the prequel, the
background information.
Now let's actually
make things fast.
So the zero thing you should
do, because you should have
done this way before you even
started looking at any of
this, is turn on GZip.
If you don't have GZip,
you're wasting a
huge amount of bandwidth.
And in fact, if you're on a
mobile device or whatever,
you're actually also wasting
latency because those devices
maybe aren't fast enough
that the bandwidth
doesn't really matter.
So you should always both get
GZipped responses and send you
GZipped requests.
The easiest way to do this
is just to use our Client
Libraries, which all do
this automatically.
If you want to do it manually,
it's sometimes a little bit
more of a pain because you have
to do things like, in the
user agent, put GZip in there
and fiddle with things to make
sure you're actually getting
a GZipped response.
It's not too bad, but it's much
easier just to say, why
not just use our Client
Libraries?
And just as a quick example, if
you look at our discovery
API, the plain, unGZipped
version of it is about 24 kB.
GZipped, it's only
11% of that size.
It's down to about 2.5 kB.
So it saves you a lot.
All right.
And that of course has almost
nothing to do with our APIs
except that our Client Libraries
do it for you.
What about things we can
actually take advantage of in
the APIs themselves?
So the first one we're going to
talk about is something we
call partial responses.
Who here is familiar with
partial responses?
Some of you, but not that many?
OK.
Good.
So you all should use this.
It's pretty cool.
The goal here is again to
save bandwidth, mostly.
And as a side effect, get a
latency benefit because the
server's sending less stuff,
so we have less things to
parse, et cetera, et cetera.
The way you do this is you
request only the portion of
the resource you care about.
So for example, if you have a
really big resource like that
discovery document, and you
only care about one or two
fields like in this example, I
only care about the IDs of the
APIs, getting all that other
stuff sent to you is just a
horrible waste of time.
So we have this query parameter
that you can add to
any of the discoverable APIs.
You just set the field's query
parameter to what you care
about, and it gives you
back only those parts.
And in this case, it gave us
back 6% of the total size.
And I'm using the non-GZipped
numbers here.
Under GZipped things would be
a little bit different.
It might save a little
bit more space
on the initial version.
So maybe it'd be
more like 10%.
But it's still a huge savings.
So just as a quick way to show
you how you can do this, I'm
going to use the APIs Explorer,
which hopefully you
guys have been hearing
a lot about.
So let's go back to my
other thing here.
And here is the APIs Explorer
that I already have loaded up.
I'm going to look at the book's
API, and I'm going to
query for a search.
So I'm going to do a search
for some books.
So anyone have book
recommendations?
AUDIENCE: Ender's Game.
SVEN MAWSON: Ender's Game,
one of my favorites.
Ender's Game.
OK.
So if I go to Ender's Game,
there's a whole bunch of stuff
I can put in here.
But when I execute, it gives
me back, hopefully you guys
can see this.
It gives back an object that
tells you how many items.
606, that's quite a lot.
And then an array of all
the items with a
whole bunch of fields.
It's got the ID, it's got the
kind, the [? e-tag, ?]
the self link.
Information about the volume,
the publisher, all kinds of
stuff, the description, ISBN
numbers, how many pages, all
this stuff.
I don't care about
any of that.
I just want to know the
title and description.
So if I just want that
information, I can go up here
and put in the fields thing.
And you could type this manually
if you want, but one
of the cool things about it API
Explorer is it actually
lets you edit this using
a tree-based system.
So I said I wanted just, and
look at all these fields that
I'm going to ignore.
This is pretty fun.
Well, let's get the author,
let's get the description, and
let's get the title.
So I do that.
It creates this nice string
for me that has all the
fields, and then if I execute
that, the result
is much, much smaller.
So you just have just the things
you care about, the
title, authors, the
description.
Much, much smaller request
makes things nice.
So now I'm going to show you how
you actually add that to
your Java code here.
And this is very similar for
other API client libraries,
but in the Java Client Library,
remember that request
object I was talking about?
Well, every single one of those
request objects has a
set fields method.
So you can just call set fields
on that request object
before executing it, and
it'll do this for you.
So in this case, for Drive, I
want the title, the download
URL, that was the one to figure
out how to get the
media, and then I want to know
what access the user has so if
I shared it with someone and
only give them view access,
when I get back into my
application I don't want to
let them edit it, right?
I want them just to be
able to view it.
So I get that back, and
then execute it.
For Tasks, it's very similar.
When I inserted it, the only
thing I needed back from the
insert was the ID, so why
not just get that?
Whoa, sorry about that.
I shouldn't have tried and
scrolled with the two fingers.
All right.
And again, you can see down here
the same kind of thing.
I just want the IDs back to
store them for syncing, so
much nicer.
With Calendar, this is actually
a little bit more
interesting situation.
I'd like to be able to set the
fields up here when I am
looking up the events so
I can get only the
fields I care about.
But the problem is, I'm
going to update these.
And if I only got the fields I
cared about, that would mean I
would be in effect deleting
the things I didn't care
about, which isn't
what I want.
So I actually have to
get everything.
So I can't do a fields
call here.
Instead, I get the
whole object.
But when I actually update
them, at least I can only
request the ID.
I don't have to request
everything.
So what does this do for us?
Well, latency-wise,
not a whole lot.
Actually there's a little noise
in here, so basically
it's the same thing.
Latency didn't really affect.
And part of the reason for this
is, this is App Engine
making a call to a Google API.
So from App Engine in Google's
cloud to an API in Google's
cloud, we have quite
a lot of bandwidth.
So it doesn't actually make much
of a latency difference.
If I had an example on, say, a
mobile application, this might
actually be a bigger
difference here.
But where you can really, really
see the difference is
when we look at the
bandwidth used.
So load didn't reduce that much,
because I actually have
to get back that whole object
from Drive, the media.
But on save, I used to get back
this huge document of the
result of saving, which
I didn't care about.
I just wanted the ID.
So just getting the ID cuts
that way, way down.
Similarly with Tasks and with
the Events, that initial read,
unfortunately I can't
do anything about.
I have to get the
whole object.
But then when I rate it, I can
basically ignore the result
and save a lot there.
So cut it by maybe a third
in both of those cases.
OK.
So I keep mentioning that on
these update cases, these sync
cases, when I read and then
write, I have to read the
whole object.
Well, not so fast.
We actually have a solution
for that.
So we call this patch.
So rather than doing a PUT where
you update the entire
resource, you do a
PATCH of just the
things you care about.
And this does two things.
One, it reduces the upstream
bandwidth that you're sending
to the server.
And two, it actually lets you,
when you're doing that read
modify write cycle, only read
the things you want.
So it actually reduces your
read bandwidth as well.
So it saves on both sides.
And again, we're saving
bandwidth, which we're
hopefully saving latency.
Although in the App Engine to
Google APIs case, not so much.
So the only difference actually
for Google servers is
you send a PATCH verb
instead of PUT.
And in the client libraries,
this will be a PATCH method
instead of an update method, for
the ones that support it.
So I've just put in a couple
examples here of what this
looks like from an
HTTP perspective.
If I was updating a Task,
normally I'd have the entire
thing, even though all I'm doing
is changing the title.
If I use PATCH, though, I can
just send that little bit.
And it's only 8% of the size, so
actually it lets me cut out
quite a lot.
So how do we actually do this?
Well, it's again very,
very simple.
In this case, this is imagining
an update of an
existing object.
And I kept mentioning the read
modify write cycle, but with
PATCH, you can actually skip the
read, if you know what you
want to change, and just go
straight to the update.
So this is what I'm
doing here.
Actually, instead of reading
the TaskList to change the
name, I just change the name.
Because I don't care what
it is right now.
I'm just going to
overwrite it.
So I create a new one
called a Patch verb.
It gives me back that
request object.
And again, I can set fields on
it, just like I could before.
Execute that, no problem.
And in Calendar now,
I'm pretty excited.
I can set that fields thing I
couldn't set before, so I set
the fields I care about,
and then I call PATCH
and submit an update.
And everything else
is just magic.
OK.
So does this help our latency?
Unfortunately, not so much.
We're in App Engine.
Bandwidth isn't helping.
But it does cut bandwidth
in those last two cases.
So when we were reading all
those Tasks and getting all
that extra information,
we can cut that out.
And even more so with Events.
Calendar is sending us all kinds
of stuff we don't care
anything about.
So we just throw that away, and
in fact we actually ask
the server to throw
it away for us.
Save some time so we get
quite a bit smaller.
It's actually less than
half the size.
So save a lot of bandwidth
there.
All right.
So that was PATCH.
The last thing I'm going to talk
about is actually doing
something about this
latency problem.
So we haven't really
been helping our
latency with all these.
One of the things my app does
that's probably not really
smart is, it's executing all
these things in serial.
So for example, if I'm updating
15 Calendar events,
I'm updating 15 Tasks, I'm
updating a Drive metadata, I'm
doing all these things,
and I'm actually
doing them in serial.
So I'm executing one, waiting
for it to return, executing
the other, waiting
for it to return.
Not the smartest way to write
and app, but actually getting
around this is kind of a pain.
You have to spin up some
threads, make everything
asynchronous, maybe start
throwing in some futures.
You have to do a lot of work to
make your life easier, to
make your life faster,
I should say.
And instead, we'll
do that for you.
So we have a feature called
Batch on all of our APIs that
lets you send all of your
requests at once, and we'll
execute them for you and
send them back to you.
And in fact, you can actually
send these on
multiple APIs at once.
So you can actually send that
request to Drive, to Calendar,
and Tasks all at the same
time in a single Batch,
and it'll just work.
It's very cool.
And the way this is done at
the HTTP level is through
multipart/mixed.
So you have a single
HTTP request.
It's a multipart.
Each of those parts is actually
another HTTP request.
So you just put them in a big
payload and send them off.
The Client Library hides
all this from you, so
don't worry about it.
But that's what actually
happens on the wire.
The server does the
parallelization for you, so
you don't have to deal with
threads and asynchronous
requests and all that.
You just send it up.
There is a slight bandwidth
costs for this because of that
envelope I was talking about.
So you have this big multipart
request, you have that outer
multipart envelope for it, and
then you also have a little
envelope around each
object for wrapping
it as an HTTP request.
Very slight cost, and
you'll see that
actually in the numbers.
The latency from this is
actually pretty variable.
It depends on what you
were doing before.
So if you were doing what I was
doing, and just executing
these in serial, it's going
to be a huge win for you.
If you already were doing all
this parallelization, it may
or may not be a win for you.
Actually it depends
on the API.
Some APIs, for example Task, as
you'll see, actually locks
its resources.
So if you're editing a TaskList,
you can only execute
one operation on that at once,
and it actually locks it.
So if you tried to do them in
parallel, in fact it would be
serial and you just
wouldn't see that.
It'd be serial on the server.
One would have to wait for the
lock to free to do it.
So if the API actually supports
making that faster,
which in fact Task doesn't but
Calendar does, which you'll
see, it can be a big win.
So we do recommend using it,
even if you've already done
all the hard work of
parallelization on your client.
It's probably better to
do it on the server.
OK.
So how do you actually
do this?
Again, it's pretty simple.
And you may have seen this
in some other talks.
Rather than executing each of
those requests objects that
we've been creating, you
add them to a Batch.
So the way this works, you
create an outer Batch.
In this case, I'm using the
Drive service to do it.
It actually doesn't matter
what service you use.
They're all the same object.
So we just call
driveService.batch, because
it's a backup Batch object,
and then we queue it up.
So we have this get file we
call queue, we give it the
Batch to add itself to, and
we give it a call back.
And to make my life a little
easier when I built this, one
of the things you may or may not
have seen in that simple
application on the bottom
left, here, I'll
actually show you it.
On the bottom left of it, you
can actually choose what
features to enable.
In a real application, of course
you'd always have all
of these on because I'm
teaching about how
awesome they are.
But to make it easier for me to
actually test things, I had
to be able to turn these things
on and off, which
complicated the code
quite a bit.
One way I uncomplicated that
for myself is creating this
callback, and I'll show you
a slide with that next.
But then once you
have all these
queued, it's really simple.
You just call execute, and
that execute call is
synchronous, and will
execute it.
And it'll actually, that call
will not return until all of
the callbacks have
been executed.
So you execute it, and all
the callbacks happen.
So the way I made
my life easier
here is Future Callback.
I'm actually using again
two features out
of the Guava library.
So there's something called
Settable Future, that does
have my name on it, and also
Listenable Future, which I
also wrote.
So a little plug for
myself there.
Bit I use what I know.
So I made these things.
You don't actually have to
get this complicated.
The actual callback methods
are very simple.
There's an onSuccess
and onFailure.
So you could do the code here
that deals with it.
You could use, for example,
atomic reference or something,
or even just a ray or a volatile
field or whatever
just to pass the data back.
And then onFailure, I'm doing
the really stupid thing of
just throwing a runtime
exception.
You'll probably want to handle
these a little smarter.
Maybe if there's multiple errors
in the Batch, handle
them in a somewhat intelligent
way, and maybe display them
all to the user.
I just throw the first one
because it's a demo.
So that was a quick segue on
futures, but let's get back to
the actual code.
So again, with Tasks,
very simple.
We just queue things
in a Batch.
And here, I'm using that Batch
I created earlier.
I don't need to create
a new one.
I can actually queue
them all up.
You just cue up that, and
then we queue up these.
And I'm actually not showing
here that in fact you needed
to execute this.
We'll see it on the next one.
Yeah, this one has
the example.
So if you're doing something
like you're inserting a new
TaskList, and then you need that
ID to do more work, well
you can't do those
all in one Batch.
So you have to do a first phase
where you execute that
first thing to get back an ID,
you read that, and then you
use that to queue up
the next ones.
So you have to do two phases
instead of being able to do it
all in one.
There's not really a way
around that without a
complicated forwarding language
that we don't have.
But the way you would do this
is, you just queue up the
first set, execute it,
create a new Batch,
queue up the next set.
Pretty simple.
So how about this?
Did this help us?
Well, yes.
It actually did.
And mostly it helped
with Calendar.
So on load, as I mentioned
earlier, with the Drive API,
you need to do get a read from
Drive to get the metadata to
get the URL to download
the file.
So you have to have
two requests.
So we used to have
three requests.
These were the Drive ones,
and this one was
the call of the Tasks.
Well, I got rid of the Tasks
one, but that wasn't that big
of a savings.
So it sped things up a little
bit, but not too much.
Same kind of thing with save.
I was doing a read and write.
I still need to do the
read and write.
So, don't save much.
Task is interesting because we
would have thought that this
would be a big win, that instead
of doing all these in
serial, I'm sending it
in one big Batch.
But as I mentioned, some back
ends don't actually support
fast batch yet.
So what this is actually doing
on the server is, you're
putting them all in parallel to
the Tasks API, which then
is blocking all of them except
one at a time, because it can
only write one at a time.
So kind of annoying.
I actually talked to the Task
team about trying to fix this,
because it annoyed me.
So if you guys notice this on
any APIs you're using, which
hopefully you won't, but if you
do, let us know and we'll
try and get that team
to implement a
faster Batch for you.
So you can see, for example,
Calendar did.
So the Calendar events are
actually batched all the way
into the storage layer.
And so you can write to one
calendar all at once, and this
ends up being a pretty
big latency win.
OK.
So that was latency, but what
happens with bandwidth?
Unfortunately, Batch actually
increases that bandwidth
because of those envelopes
I was talking about.
So you can see here, especially
on save, it
increased it a bit, and
on Tasks, quite a lot.
The response from Tasks was
so small that adding those
envelopes to every single one
of those requests ended up
being a lot more.
So I'm going to give you a quick
demo of how this looks
with everything put together.
So let's actually create a
new Super List for this.
So we're going to call
this Books to Read.
And we said that we wanted
to do Ender's Game.
And let's read, any
other books?
Anyone?
Come on.
People like books
still, right?
Movies?
AUDIENCE: Name of the Wind.
SVEN MAWSON: What was that?
SVEN MAWSON: Name of the Wind.
That's a good one.
Name of the Wind.
I see our audience likes
sci fi things.
OK.
Children of the Sky.
I'm reading that now.
Vernor Vinge, if any of
you guys know him.
He came to Google recently.
AUDIENCE: Cosmic Trigger.
SVEN MAWSON: Cosmic Trigger.
All right.
OK So we have some books.
Let's set some due
dates on these.
When I should read these by, I
don't really know what due
date means on a book,
but we'll set it.
I'm going to read really fast
here, and I should finish all
of this by the end
of next week.
And let's actually--
so we save that.
And we're actually going to
also create a TaskList for
this, so I can show you how to
link all these together.
So this is actually creating
a list back in My
TaskLists for this.
And I can sync it.
So let's just be quick
and add some items.
Just to give you guys a flavor
for how this stuff works.
I can edit some things.
I don't think I'll finish
that quite then.
All right.
So here it is.
Let's save it and let's see
how long this takes.
Still going, still going,
still going.
Doing all that in serial, you
can see all this stuff gets
printed here.
The whole thing took
seven seconds.
So let's turn on all
of our features.
Let's delete some items.
Better item.
Let's add some more things,
let's change some dates.
Just to give it something
to do here.
And then let's save it.
And hopefully this will be
faster if the demigods are
nice to me, but maybe not.
Ooh, maybe not.
Oh, it took longer.
Well, let's pretend
it was faster.
It was faster when I tried this
earlier, but, all right.
So in the earlier version of
this that I tried, here's how
much faster it was.
Unfortunately, it didn't quite
work for the demo.
And this is actually, what I
wanted to show you is how much
Batch makes a difference
when you're doing a lot
of actions at once.
So I was showing you applying
a Batch just to read it from
Drive, and then applying a Batch
just to read it from
Calendar, and then applying a
Batch just to read from Tasks.
But as I mentioned, you can
do this all at once.
You don't have to just
do one API at a time.
You can actually do everything
at once.
And that means everything
gets parallelilized.
Even in that annoying fact that
the Event stuff took a
long time because the back end's
not optimized, so the
amount of time that that took is
the time everything takes,
because everything else
is done already.
So here you can see that.
The full sync is a save with a
bunch of items from Task I'm
going to turn into Calendar.
And it saves a whole
bunch of time.
I actually wrote down, just
so I can tell you the cool
numbers here.
So this is 63% of the time, so
almost half the time got
thrown away just because
I was using Batch.
So it's pretty nice.
And I should mention also the
quite rigorous testing
principle here was I ran
this about 10 times
and took the median.
So not too exciting.
OK.
What about bandwidth, right?
So same kind of thing,
full sync.
You can see those first two
features on latency really
didn't really make
a difference.
On bandwidth, they were
a huge difference.
Partial responses and Patch
cut out a lot of the time.
Partial itself cut out
half the time.
Patch cut out another
half of that.
Unfortunately, the Batch, we're
paying a slight overhead.
So in order to get that fast
latency, we pay a little bit
in the bandwidth.
We're back up to 42%
of the original.
Still better than just
Partial by itself.
So in summary, how much
can you expect to
save with these features?
So GZip, Partial, and Patch,
I'm all marking as N/A for
latency, because it's really the
bandwidth that may or may
not save you the latency.
They don't have a direct effect
on latency, but they do
have a big savings
on bandwidth.
So GZip by itself can
save you 79%,
depending on your content.
Things like a JSON payload,
which are APIs return, tend to
be very regular.
The same key names appear,
the same field names,
often the same data.
So it really can GZip
really, really well.
So definitely use that.
Partial can save, depending on
what field you use, between
40% and 80%.
Of course, if you ask for
everything, it doesn't save
you anything.
Patch can save an additional
40% to 70% on top of that.
And then Batch, of course,
costs you that envelope
overhead, but it can give you
huge latency savings.
So it's definitely worth it.
All right.
So pretty much all I have.
I just wanted to give you a
bunch of information about
some links you can go
to to learn more.
So on the Discovery API and
the Drive API, there's a
performance page.
The links are there.
You can read about all
these features.
Actually, I think you can't read
about Batch yet, because
it's still pretty new.
But we'll be adding
that very shortly.
And then there's also a webinar
that you guys may or
may not have seen on getting
started with our APIs.
If any of you want to get up to
speed, you could use that.
And then there's a whole bunch
of related sessions, on
optimizing in general, there's
stuff about how to optimize
the web applications, there's
one at 5:15 today.
There's optimizing your Google
App Engine app, which I
probably should've gone to, it
might have made my app faster.
I think there's also some
mobile ones I don't have
listed here.
And then there's a bunch of
talks about how to use our API
clients, so there was a talk
about using the JavaScript
client, and there's a code
lab on it tomorrow.
There's a talk about Android
applications, I think also at
5:15 today.
There's also a code lab
on that tomorrow.
You can learn about
all these things.
And then there's also this
really cool feature we just
launched called Cloud Endpoints,
hopefully you guys
know about.
One of the very cool things
about that is it's built on
our infrastructure, so you get
all of this stuff on your own
APIs if you build on
Cloud Endpoints.
So you get the partial feature,
you get the patch
feature, and you get Batch.
So it's pretty cool.
All right.
That is all I had.
Thank you guys very much.
And I will take questions, and
please use the microphones.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned how it'd
be better to use
PATCH instead of PUT.
Does AppEngine support PATCH?
Because all our applications
are on AppEngine.
SVEN MAWSON: So on sending
a patch, you mean?
So if you use the--
so actually, I'm using
AppEngine and I'm
doing that in these.
So hopefully you use our Client
Libraries, which will
do it for you.
That said, the way the Client
Library is probably doing it,
I'm not 100% sure on this, is we
have a header that you can
override the HTTP method in case
the environment you're
using doesn't support it.
So it might be doing that, but
our Client Libraries will do
that for you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
You said we should ask to
compress the responses, right?
At some point, I guess, we
need to uncompress them.
Don't we lose time
when we do that?
SVEN MAWSON: Right.
So the CPU overhead of GZip?
I skipped over that part.
Yes, there is a CPU
overhead of GZip.
Devices are so fast these days,
it's almost nonexistent.
I mean, I would measure it.
The rule number one of
performance is always measure.
So test it out and see if GZip,
depending on the exact
device you're targeting,
if it makes sense.
Our Client Libraries enable
GZip by default, but they
actually have an easy way to
turn it off, if you do need to
turn it off.
But I would say, don't turn it
off unless you have strong
evidence that it's causing
a problem, because it'll
actually save a lot of time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SVEN MAWSON: Yeah.
Any other questions?
All right, you all.
Thanks for your time.
[APPLAUSE]